we had a very tragic incident today here  at the king supers  there was loss of life we have multiple  people who were killed in this incident  and i am sorry to have to report that  one of them was a boulder police officer  during this trying time i would ask the  media  and the public to honor the privacy  of the officer's family and his  co-workers here at the police department  i will also share that we got tremendous  support  from our fellow law enforcement agencies  both in boulder county  which some of them you see behind me the  fbi  atf and other denver metro  agencies without that quick response  we don't know um if there would have  been more loss of life  i can share with the public today or  this this evening  that there is no ongoing public threat  that we do have a person of interest in  custody  that person was injured during the  incident  and is being treated for the injuries